aloha reject nation greg alba here john
approaching the end of the week and dis
discovered a Deadpool thingy dropped
it's called apologies with david to to
David Beckham I hope they're it's a joke
I'll get otherwise we're gonna get a lot
of hate radiance I don't remember
exactly where this came from but didn't
he make like a David Beckham's voice
joke or something like that at one point
that does sound a little familiar yeah I
remember I remember David Beckham and
when he opens his mouth and then some
like banter joke oh yeah yeah I'm
speaking of David's patient add a shout
out for David Gandy today because a
David Beckham be he gave me this awesome
shirt I don't you guys can see it's a
little Deadpool right there haha I see a
little Tyrone magnet for David for this
shout out what I wanted to tell you was
something sincere I love that picture
you sent me of your I really appreciate
that
oh man I spent hours just you are and
I'm trying to avoid a yellow dollar bill
song and I really enjoyed the picture of
John Wayne I also masturbate hope you
like your shout out let's watch this
that's what it is
David Beckham speak so he mouths X the
can of helium
I am so sorry so so so
[Music]
tickets for the cup
I can't wait to not watch Italy play the
Netherlands columns I'm mad at you
Healing hugs
[Music]
so good
manhood no no no let go of this burden
together
just wonderful no you apologizing for
anyway
we're just debating Deadpool with that
your voice doesn't ring a bell
what did you think I was apologizing for
I mean there's a list Green Lantern yep
RIPD
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Ryan Reynolds is not Deadpool
Deadpool is Ryan Reynolds name like
Batman the real Ryan Reynolds is just a
red suit white eyes they have really
upped their game in the marketing
department and the callin stuff out
department it's funny because recently
Ryan Reynolds was doing some interview
where he was like there are movies that
I've made that people don't like but I
really liked it he also said I didn't
actually see the final cut of the Green
Lantern so I'm not gonna sit here and
say if I liked it or not but you're
right out he's just going yep they're
all terrible movies not saying that yeah
very saying it adds dead-letter Ryan
Reynolds and interviews wouldn't admit
those things for some reason well yeah I
feel like as Deadpool he has more
license to maybe also acknowledge just
what the general feeling about all those
movies was yeah and probably their
performance as well so in that way I can
see it maybe along with you know just
the mystique that Deadpool has to poke
fun and everything that maybe he can get
away with that better year than he
couldn't an interview there's so many
comic book movies Reynolds was a part of
oh yeah there's way more than Green
Lantern no I don't forgot about RIPD
yeah I feel like you might have enjoyed
RIPD though really I mean it looks like
fun making it more fun than the other
one side like I heard Wesley Snipes on
blade Trinity was a nightmare to work
well no and I heard he said this very
mean to Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern
looks like no one wanted to be on that
set that's where he met his wife one
good thing came out of that one good
thing came out of that Expo
yeah I realize that we've seen a couple
of trailers for this film that tell us
some of the plot when I think about the
movie I'm like I really I'm not sure
what I'm getting into this time there's
a couple of people I met and one person
specifically said that films crazy like
that's all I can say yes like it's a
crazy film he's they prefer over
infinity more crazy especially with a
movie like Deadpool is like the most
exciting review I ya have possibly heard
yeah it's like if I'm going in expecting
crazy that's what I want yeah I hope it
goes crazy yeah I really hope it
commences I don't need any more
specifics than that
and their Metta marketing just keeps
getting better and better by the second
next week people look out for our movie
review anyway guys you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and David Gandy
on all sincere Ness next one talk about
uh oh yeah okay so you're like looking
through a keyhole and you you wanted to
show up at the door and like you can
like look through them at the at the
hole
glory glory hole no anus
what's an anus